hi i'm carlos busamandi with et canada
pleasure to see you how are you you too
i'm good how are you
um i'm great and i'm very very very
excited for this the
since the trailer dropped fans have been
looking at details of this world and the
story you're gonna tell
um
and there's a lot to get into what
you've you have said that you like
became more of a fan of star wars over
the course of this not being a super fan
coming into this right so i'm curious
like
what are the advantages of coming into
this without having been a super fan
previously
i think the biggest is coming into it at
the top
being able to go to work and it's sort
of demystified i don't have to sort of
you know push past a lot to get to what
it is i'm able to just go to work and
kind of just do my job which i'm really
grateful for and i think getting to know
it in this way you know the characters
and the people
um
it's connected to so many personal
moments now for me
um certainly
something that has changed my life
personally and um
yeah
i i feel more grateful to have become a
fan in this way than i think i would
have
the other way around
that's awesome who though in your life
was the biggest super fan that was like
yo what do you do in star wars let me in
i want to know like who was that person
yeah i think maybe
honestly i think all of my friends i
think
super fan or not everyone realizes
oh snap you doing star wars
like it's really crazy for everybody so
it's it's exciting to it was exciting to
be able to tell them that first time and
what's happening now that's really
interesting
is
my friends are like
oh you're really in it
i thought you were gonna be like i
didn't realize okay so you're in star
wars they're like you're in it in it
you're understanding like you're
analyzing it
yeah yeah i'm in in it thing
well this has been like a really big
couple of years for you just even just
as a fan watching between uh mean
eminence for the queen's gambit um
i mean doing the tragedy of macbeth and
then this like how does it feel
knowing that you're like like riding
this wave right now
it's wild and um i try to stay present
every step of the way
um i recognize and feel
how fast it's moving but at the same
time it doesn't really feel that fast at
all on the inside because it's
it seems quick but it's also like years
in the making you know what i mean and
so i feel blessed to be in this moment
and i'm just trying to be as present as
i can
very cool well um i'm super excited for
you we're all super fast excited for you
can't wait to see the show can't wait
all the best bye